[Musique]
merci de nous rejoindre pour un nouvel
entretien politique sur tv 78
aujourd'hui je reçois pierre l'ush
bonjour vous êtes le référent de la
république en marche dans le département
des yvelines dans cinq mois se déroulera
l'élection présidentielle dans six mois
les élections législatives où en est la
république en marche pour ces deux
prochains scrutins est ce que les choses
se préparent déjà oui écouter on a fait
notre rentrée politique il ya deux
semaines à mézières sur seine on avait
200 250 militants qui étaient présents
on a eu la visite de l'indiana et de
gabriel attal qui sont venus prendre un
peu la température
du terrain on a passé un bon moment et
depuis le début septembre tournée est
revenu sur le terrain faire du porte à
porte avec une grande opération qui a
été lancé notamment samedi dernier à
poissy par elisabeth board
on est tous très content de revenir
vraiment librement et totalement
en confiance auprès des français à leur
écoute c'est essentiellement une passe
on découpe on est là pour y répondre aux
questions des français sur le bilan des
manuels macron d'un aussi là pour faire
ce bilan avec eux en leur demandant on
l'a questionnaire qui les interroge
beaucoup sur ce qu'ils ont aussi fait du
bien de moins bien qu'est ce qu'on peut
améliorer qu'est ce qui a changé dans
leur vie et qui va nous aider aussi nous
a fait des propositions politiques pour
la suite qui tenait aujourd'hui lrm dans
les yvelines représente quoi en terme
d'adhérents déjà alors on a treize mille
deux cents adhérents dans le département
ils se regroupent dans une cinquantaine
de comités locaux ce qui change beaucoup
depuis 2010 est c'est qu'on a maintenant
après 340 élus locaux des conseillers
municipaux principalement qui en fait en
plus de leurs compétences
militante et professionnels qui nous
apportait des cracks vous apporte aussi
maintenant un regard nouveau
complémentaires sur le terrain alors
2010 16 qui change aussi 2017 emmanuel
macron était le candidat surprise en
quelque sorte 2022 la surprise viendrait
plutôt d'eric zemmour il reste autour
des 17 % on pourrait aussi regarder les
scores les sondages pour marine le pen
troisième 16% toujours c'est des
chiffres de fin de semaine dernière pour
l'institut harris globalement est ce que
ces chiffres-là cette montée des
extrêmes aussi si on additionne ces
chiffres vous inquiète c'est la montée
des extrêmes c'est un peu le marronnier
électoral depuis depuis plus d'un an des
élections force est de constater que
leur résultat est très stable depuis
2012 voire même en diminution au niveau
des sélections régionales par exemple on
a vu que le nombre de voix engrangées
par les extrêmes était beaucoup plus
faible qu'aux pas vous c'est nous on ne
s'inquiète pas de des extrêmes on
s'inquiète de la situation des français
et on a essayé de leur apporter des
réponses concrètes et réalistes là où se
tourne par exemple si on regarde les
sondages ce faire eric zemmour c'est
aussi peut-être parce qu'il n'apprécie
pas ou ne soutiennent pas les
propositions qui sont faites les
réponses qui sont apportées par le
gouvernement en place il ya celle de
vases communicants en fait qui soutient
et zemmour sont des gens qui hier
soutenait marine le pen ou soutenait la
droite des républicains à l'heure
actuelle on ne ne vois pas de siphonnage
de voies de migration des lecteurs
modéré vers vers un nouveau candidat ex
quoi qu'il en soit comme il ya cinq ans
les marcheurs dont vous faites partie
donc sont repartis sur le terrain ils
posent les différentes questions il y en
a 9 ans tous dans ce questionnaire qui a
été prévu élaborés pour faire les
français votre plus grande inquiétude ce
qui vous a déplu dans ce quinquennat ce
qui vous a plu si je vous retourne la
question justement qu'est-ce qui vous a
déplu dans ce quinquennat et qu'est ce
qui vous a plu dans ce quinquennat
qu'est ce qui m'a déplu dans ce
quinquennat c'est c'est probablement le
fait que par la force des choses on n'a
pas pu faire tout ce qu'on avait annoncé
vouloir faire je pense à la réforme des
retraites par exemple ou avancer plus
sur les sujets de la fin de vie ou de la
dépendance même si on a pu déjà posé les
premières pierres sur ce sujet très
important la dépendance ce qui me plaît
particulièrement dans ce qui a été fait
de ce quinquennat c'est un certain
nombre de réformes
sociale mais aussi sociétales de
changement de philosophie je pense par
exemple à l'annoncé le jour du contrat
engagement jeunes qui revoit totalement
comment on construit une relation d aide
sociale à la jeunesse où on va pas aller
se contenter de leur donner de l'argent
en disant débrouillez vous avec cet
argent qu'on vous donne mais on va les
accompagner on va les aider à retrouver
le chemin de la formation de l'emploi
pour ne pas que l'aide sociale sur une
fatalité et c'est ce refus du fatalisme
c'est cette ambition de faire sortie à
l'écran de la pauvreté et qui qui a mené
l'action sociale dans le quinquennat et
ça j'en suis très fier revenons un peu
sur l'élection les élections qui
s'annoncent pour gagner des élections il
faut aussi faire des alliances comment
se passe les rapports avec le modem
notamment est ce qu'une alliance solide
va se mettre en place aussi et puis
surtout comment cela va fonctionner
parce qu'on a bien vu sur les dernières
régionales par exemple qu'au sein du
modem il pouvait y avoir des tensions et
des différences de points de vue sur
quel candidat et quel candidat de
soutenir en ile de france une partie du
modem préféré soutenir valérie pécresse
une autre partie était allié aussi avec
lrm donc comment ça va s'organiser pour
les prochains mois je n'ai aucun doute
sur le fait qu'avec le modem ça se passe
très très bien pour l'élection
présidentielle on a les mêmes ambitions
pour la france on a la même envie que
emmanuel macron sans être candidat et
soit réélu pour cinq ans de plus j'ai
aucun doute là dessus moi ce que je
remarque c'est que l'assise du prison
d'un public son soutien s'est élargit
considérablement depuis 2010 est au sein
de la classe politique on a maintenant
dans les ive et une quarantaine de
comité de soutien créé par des élus
locaux qui ne sont pas encartés à blick
en marche et qui ont décidé d'apporter
un soutien au président de la république
en reconnaissant le travail qui avait
été fait et en reconnaissant
l'importance de ce qui allait encore
avoir à faire dans les années à venir
mais son côté la présidentielle les
législatives
le scrutin important aussi pour ensuite
donner une majorité au prochain
gouvernement certains candidats et
certains députés en tout cas des
yvelines ont déjà annoncé leur souhait
aussi de se représenter est-ce qu'ils
ont déjà tout votre soutien ou c'est
encore un peu prématuré je pensais à
didier baichère marie le bec encreur
berger
la chance dans les yvelines d'avoir des
députés qui ont été pourtant présents
sur le terrain et à l'assemblée qui ont
une entière une relation avec les
consignes dans sa construction avec les
militants ils ont évidemment tout mon
soutien s'il souhaite s'il souhaite
continuer et sûr dans la 12e
circonscription on sait déjà en revanche
que florent secondes lui elle ne sera
pas candidate à nouveau ça veut dire que
le casting est déjà ouvert vous y
réfléchissez déjà alors le casting n'est
pas ouvert puisque le mouvement se
concentre essentiellement sur les
élections présidentielles pour le moment
c'est ce qui c'est l'objectif principal
c'est là où tous nos efforts se
concentrent et il sera temps de parler
des initiatives plus tard il y aura un
enjeu important parce que dans les
yvelines il n'y a pas réussi avec l om
un grand chelem mais quasiment même si
depuis la 10e circonscription aussi
était a été perdu après le départ de
deux années est philippe benassaya pour
les républicains avaient récupéré cette
circonscription
aujourd'hui c'est ce serait ce serait
difficile pour vous de perdre des
circonscriptions je pose cette question
là parce que sur les élections
intermédiaires jusqu'à présent elles
mêmes n'a pas réalisé de très bons
scores donc ya pas forcément une des
motifs d'être rassurés pour ses
prochaines ses prochains scrutins on
sait que les élections intermédiaires
sont toujours difficiles pour les les
partis politiques en place j'ai aucun
doute qu'on arrivera à faire aussi bien
que la majorité présidentielle pourra
conserver c'est sa contribution et
pourquoi pas
gagner celle qui sait lequel n'a pas
lieu en 2017 et ça passe aussi par un
rapprochement avec des des ténors de la
droite dont six antennes orge comme ça
un os péricard à saint-germain-en-laye
karl olive aussi qu'ils soutiennent tous
les deux emmanuel macron et les oem
convenu testing n'est pas encore ouvert
et on
on discutera en temps et en heure avec
avec nos alliés et les personnes qui ont
entretenu une prise en a plus votre
calendrier pour la suite des réunions
sont prévues avec les militants ce
questionnaire qui est prévu vous allez
vous organiser comment pour aller à la
rencontre des électeurs on va déjà se
déplacer tous les week-ends les comités
locaux seront mobilisés dans différents
quartiers faire du porte à porte sur les
marchés et on on prévoira plutôt enviés
des réunions publiques pour rencontrer
vos pulsions merci beaucoup pire lui se
référant la république en mars dans lé
yvelines on se retrouve très bientôt sur
tv 78 pour un prochain entretien
politique
[Musique]